- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is take your shot.
Over to you, Kevin Smith.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I go into the emergency
room, and I was like,
"Donald Smith?" and they're like,
"I'm sorry, he passed," and
they took me into the room.
There's my father laying
on a gurney, just dead.
He still has a tube sticking
out of him where they were
trying to intubate him
or something like that,
but just motionless, quiet,
no breathing whatsoever,
and it was weird to say the least.
You always know eventually
your parents are going to go,
but I wasn't ready, I wasn't
ready for that moment.
And then I walked out, and I went outside
and had a cigarette, I was
still a cigarette smoker
in those days, and I
was just thinking about
being half an orphan or
halfway to being an orphan
or something like that.
My brother comes out, and I was like,
"Oh, can't believe it, right?"
He goes, "Yeah, it's pretty tough."
And I said, "How was it?"
because my brother was there.
He was staying with my parents.
And Donald, without missing
a beat, my brother goes,
"Dad died screaming,"
and I was like, "What?"
and he goes, "Dad died screaming."
I said, "What do you mean?"
He's like, "Well he woke up,
and he was kicking the sheets
"off and screaming about being
on fire, and he was so hot
"and so hot and get him
water and fucking screaming.
"The screaming got louder and louder,
"and it reached a fever
pitch, and he died.
"And I don't know how else to
say it but dad died screaming"
and that hit me like a Mac
truck, and I remember thinking,
"Oh my god, in this world,
where even a good man
"like my old man is
going to die screaming,
"there's no point in not trying to achieve
"every dream that I have."
This is my eventual end.
One day, that's it.
And I really felt like,
man, that's like...
This is my future, we're all
probably going to go out screaming
so the best thing to do prior to that
is to try to pack that life with as much
wonderfulness, fun, productivity.
Surround yourself with
people that are going to
help you do that because in this world,
there's not a lot of support.
There's a lot of negativity,
there's a lot of cynicism.
Even as I sit here and tell
that story about my father dying
I guarantee you there's a
cynical head in this house,
maybe more, sitting
there going, "Who cares?
"Move on, tell a dick joke."
The world is full of why.
Man, you tell people something,
they'll tell you why.
Throw a rock, and you'll
hit somebody with why.
Like, "Hey, man, I want to make a movie."
"Why, why do you think you can do that?
"Why, nobody else is doing
it, why are you doing it?"
There's so much why.
You go out and you find why not.
You surround yourself with why not.
People that are just like, "why not,"
when you're like, "hey, man,
I'm going to try something."
They're like, "Why not,
let's give it a shot."
People who try to help you do
your dreams, make your dreams
come true, and shouldn't
you do the same for them?
We're all in this together,
and it cost nothing
to encourage a artist.
That's why I get up here
for almost 20 years now
after the movie, man, there
ain't a lot of filmmakers
get up after the movie and spend more time
than the movie itself talking,
but I've been trying to
impart one simple lesson
for nearly 20 years, anybody can do this,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, I wasn't born into a
business or the film business
or born with a mic in my hands.
I have no discernible
talent whatsoever, man.
I have no connections to the business.
We're from New Jersey and stuff.
I got lucky, somebody picked up the movie
and boom, I was off and running,
and part of that manifests,
when you're brought into
the indie film community,
part of your job, part of your
honor, part of your privilege
is to make sure that keeps
going to encourage other people.
You know, to tell people
it's worth the shot
just like Wayne Gretzky
said, you miss 100%
of the shots you never take.
It's always worth the shot.
Now, if you're talking about, like,
if what your shot is, you're just like,
"I've always wanted to
kill 12 children, Kevin."
Don't take that shot at all.
I'm not talking about that, you know,
I'm talking about artsy shit.
You know, writing a blog, making
some music, making a movie,
making a cupcake store or knitting store,
or putting together a YouTube clip,
just anything that's just
not, "Oh, we must do this
"because it's part of my
job, or this will get money."
Some shit you just do just
to see if it can be done.
Live a why not life,
man, because we're all
going to die screaming, so make
sure when you die screaming,
you're totally fulfilled, you're like,
"I took all the shots, I did it.
"I went after everything I
wanted to or at least tried."
Take the shot, the shot
is always worth taking.
Whether it's a dopey thing like podcasting
or writing a book or writing a blog.
Think about the encouragement you get,
when you encourage an artist, think about
the potential that comes out of it.
You tell a dude good job,
man, that person maybe one day
writes that blog that you
meme out to the entire world
because it says exactly what
you've always wanted to say
but couldn't yourself,
or they write that song
that you play over and
over after a loved one dies
because it means the world to you.
Or they make that movie
that is the one you cling to
when everything is going wrong in life.
Oh, you pop that in, and things
aren't bad for two hours.
All that comes from encouraging an artist.
Nothing good comes from
discouraging an artist.
So for 20 years, I keep
coming up here and going,
"Go out and do it, why
the aren't you doing this?
"It's so fun, you should do it."
Take your shot, I took my shot,
and it's nothing but pussy
and donuts, you know?
So I'm here to tell you,
man, give it a shot.
Go out and try.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
The question of the day today is
what was the biggest
shot that you have taken?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Shishir Shenoy from
Shenoy International.
Thank you so much, so much, so much
for buying a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going